you remember that time republicans said
they couldn't stop democratic spending
if they were minority in congress so
conservatives elected them to majority
remember that time the republicans said
they couldn't stop democratic spending
if they were minority in the Senate so
conservatives elected them to a majority
you remember that time republicans said
they couldn't stop democratic spending
if they didn't have the white house
since the president could just use the
bully pulpit to blame republicans for a
government shutdown so conservatives
elected trump president yeah republicans
relying Republicans now have the
opportunity to pass continuing funding
for the federal government through the
budget process this would be an
excellent time to make approval of
funding contingent on the funding of
various democratic priorities after all
if Democrats attempt to shut down the
government presumably president Trump
can rail against them by publicly
blaming them for harming Americans just
like Obama did to Republicans but that's
not what's happening as daniel horowitz
right to conservative review Senate
Republicans have not only guaranteed
Democrats they will give them all the
policies and spending levels in the
budget bill but they will also jettison
the president's request for a
supplemental spending bill for
construction of the border wall along
with spending offsets so what kind of
garbage our Republican is funding this
time in order to avoid a government
shutdown fight you remember the same
kind of fight they said a minority party
could never win back in 2013 when Ted
Cruz tried to defund Obamacare first
they're going to keep funding for
Planned Parenthood so five minutes ago
president Trump was tweeting about how
the freedom caucus had maintained
federal funding for Planned Parenthood
by not going along with Trump care now
we learned that according to the hell
Paul Ryan quote sought to avoid another
political landmine on Tuesday by arguing
that language defunding Planned
Parenthood should be kept out of the
spending legislation he now says instead
he once did a fun planned parenthood the
reconciliation so do it speaker Ryan
what is stopping you aside from your own
political cowardice second they said
that they're going to keep funding for
Obamacare so Republicans had time after
time during the Obama administration
that if they kept funding continuing
budget resolutions they'd be funding
Obamacare now the Republicans control
the whole process and they're still
going to fund Obamacare why because the
Democrats might shut down the government
Senator Dick Durbin said that
Republicans would be blamed for a shot
down because they control all the
branches of the government but we are
told by Republicans that minority
parties shutting down the government
damages minority parties so what the
hell finally apparently they're not
going to fund the Trump wall Republicans
now say they won't provide the three
bill
dollars in funding requested by the
Trump administration to build a border
wall which was of course Trump's top
campaign promise they won't do it
because they're afraid of democratic
filibuster of course so it appears that
the new standard for Republicans is that
the government must never shut down
under any circumstances which doesn't
actually make them very different from
Democrats does it I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show okay so i want a
lot to get to today i'm going to begin
today with the meltdown and democratic
party be kind of self the self
immolation of the democratic party but
then we have to get to the
self-immolation of the Republican Party
which is twice as dramatic and twice is
unacceptable considering that they're
the majority party in Congress and they
have the presidency so we'll start with
the Democrats who for some reason have
decided to rush headlong over the
Gorsuch cliff so right now polls show
the two to one American sync the judge
Gorsuch ought to get an up or down vote
on the Supreme Court now to be fair
polls showed that people thought that
Merrick garland should get an up or down
vote on the Supreme Court but
Republicans weren't damaged by that
because nobody really cares all that
much I don't think people care all that
much about the gore such thing the real
problem here is not the public opinion
polls the real problem for Democrats is
that if they use the filibuster on
Gorsuch and Republicans than nuke to
filibuster next time from comes back
with the swing vote let's anthony
kennedy resigns and suddenly Trump has
that fifth vote on the Supreme Court
Democrats will have already nuke the
filibuster so they will have no option
but to basically sit there in line so
what they would be smarter off doing a
sale of course which is a good consensus
nominee will pass him through and then
next time that's when you have the
filibuster fight you say this is the
fifth vote on the Supreme Court we can't
have somebody who's so far right-wing we
need somebody who's a consensus pick
that would be the smart politics of the
situation but that's not what they're
doing and that's because everybody on
the Democratic side hates from so much
that they're not even willing to to
engage in smart politics in order to
hurt him which is an incredible thing
here's Chuck Schumer opposing the
nomination of Judge Gorsuch that's why
he's having trouble learning 60 votes
there was a seismic change after his
hearing there were suspicions about
judge Gorsuch when you look at his early
writings and who we hung out with and
particularly that it was on a list that
put the heritage foundation who most
Republicans think is too far the right
was chosen from that list he was chosen
from dulles chuck schumer so chuck
schumer clearly has no idea what he's
talking about he kind of loses his train
of thought in the middle there and
starts thinking about how nice would be
to be on a beach not talking about judge
Gorsuch because this is a losing issue
for democrats the democrats just
continue to maintain that Trump is going
to fall apart of his own accord they're
not going to have to do anything to push
it and so they may as well just oppose
him at every turn Maxine Waters whose
hair most definitely does not look like
james brown hair stop saying that Maxine
Waters said the Trump doesn't deserve to
be President and so he came to the
presidency or with the kind of character
and background that made me distrust him
not honor him and not respect him and of
course he got the presidency because he
was able to get those votes from those
few states that put him made him the
winner rather and so he's the President
of the United States people are still
talking about he's going to change he's
going to become presidential he has not
changed he is not presidential as a
matter of fact he's worse now than even
he was in the campaign and I think that
he does not deserve to represent us in
the world we're being good looking I
mean if this is a real plan here the
real plan is just that they're going to
rail against Trump for the next four
years that would give Republicans a
major opportunity and what would give
Republicans even more of an opportunity
is the fact that the only real scandal
on the table that we actually know about
at this point is the intelligence
community leaking so people have talked
about this may I said the side infinitum
at this point the the fact is that
everybody's talking about Trump Russia
are the connections between Trump and
the Russian government supposedly there
hasn't been a shred of evidence right
now showing coordination between the
Trump team or the Trump campaign and the
Russian government zero shreds of
evidence lots and lots and lots of
evidence however that the Obama
intelligence community was widely
disseminating information attempting to
essentially implicate the Trump team in
Russian ties and foreign ties so a
former Obama intelligence official this
video has been around for probably three
weeks but now it's sort of being passed
around again because of trumps
accusations this former Obama
intelligence official issues I guess a
former assistant deputy secretary of
defense she says that it was clear that
in the last days of the Obama
tration she along with other people was
encouraging a lot of people in the
intelligence community to widely
disseminate information about President
Trump in order to basically make sure
that the Trump team didn't come in and
destroy it so here's what she had to
face what 16 it would more actually
aimed aimed at telling the hill people
get as much as information as you can
get as much intelligence as you can
before President Obama leaves the
administration
and in what she actually says there is
she says that they raced to basically
pump out information on Trump she said I
had a fear that some of that information
would disappear when senior Obama people
left so be hidden away in the
bureaucracy that Trump folks if they
found out how we knew what we knew about
their Trump staff dealing with Russians
that they would try to compromise those
sources and methods meaning we no longer
have access to that intelligence so I
became very worried because not enough
was coming out into the open and I knew
that there was more we have very good
intelligence on Russia so then I had
talked to some of my former colleagues
and I knew that they were trying to also
get help infra to get information to the
hill her name is Evelyn Farkas and she
was the deputy assistant secretary of
defense under President Obama so she's
basically saying that there was
information there and we were widely
trying to disseminate it specifically
with the goal that it would become
public okay it would be illegal for all
of this unmasking you know the unmasking
of Mike Flynn for example the National
Security Advisor that's actually illegal
you can't just throw out wiretapping
information on American citizens even if
they were caught up in form wiretap it
can't just throw that information out
there and then pretend like nothing bad
happened that is legal violation
Democrats are ignoring a scandal that
obviously is real in favor of a scandal
that may very well be fake the Trump
Russell scandal the Trump administration
continues to deny it so the Democrats
really have nothing here they're
basically just hoping that the
Republicans set themselves on fire
fortunately that's a pretty good bad so
the Republicans have decided that it
will be totally worthwhile to set
themselves on fire president Trump
yesterday he was speaking at the White
House and some people he said don't
worry health care is going to be easy i
love that he's continuing to say this
after the failure of Trump care and
demonstrated a little bit of a
disconnect airs president from and I
know that we're all going to make a deal
on health care that's such an easy one
so I have no doubt that that's going to
happen very quickly I think it will
actually I think it's going to happen
because we've all been promising
Democrat Republican we've all been
promising that to the American people so
I think a lot of good things are going
to happen there ok what does Trump
actually want to do here when he
actually wants to do here as he wants to
come up with some sort of bipartisan
plan so that's not going to happen look
at look at chuck schumer stalling on
Gorsuch was a consensus nominee if ever
there was one got zero votes against him
when he was elevated to the appeals
court under under george w bush here he
is saying that he basically wants a
consensus plan and then just to double
down on that today Donald Trump wants
or openly with the freedom caucus again
so here's what he tweeted he tweeted the
freedom caucus will hurt the entire
Republican agenda if they don't get on
the team and fast we must fight them and
ends in 2018 we must fight them in 20
the freedom clock can mean the
Conservatives you mean the tea party
people who are a large constituent
senior base need to elect muy Gohmert
who openly campaign for you and Mark
meadows who openly campaign for you
those are the people you have to fight
because they voted against Trump care
Donald Trump is now trying to
triangulate he's trying to do a Bill
Clinton except that he owns the Congress
okay Clinton waited until Republicans
around the Congress to triangulate Trump
is preemptively trying to triangulate
the problem is Democrats are not
interested in working with president
Trump this follows hard by the way on
last week's tweet storm targeting the
freedom caucus over the failure of his
trump care plan you recall we talked
about it at length he said Democrats are
smiling in DC that the freedom caucus
with the help of club for growth and
heritage have saved Planned Parenthood a
no care now as you'll recall five
seconds ago I just told you about how
the Trump administration alone would
speaker Ryan are going to preserve
Planned Parenthood funding in the
current budget deal because they're
afraid of Democrats so who's preserving
Planned Parenthood funding oh that's
right it's the establishment and
president Trump but now it's clear that
Trump is trying to go to war with these
conservatives and he's figuring one of
two things one can peel off enough
conservatives from the freedom caucus to
vote with him on future bills by
threatening them that didn't work out
well last time or two he's figuring that
by yelling at the freedom caucus
suddenly Democrats will be warmer to him
which is idiocy the Democrats are not
going to work with president Trump they
think that he's vulnerable they have
their boot on his throat and they
figured that he's a thirty-five percent
approval rating right now if they just
keep demonstrating that he's ineffective
and unable to get anything done he'll be
down in the 20s for Trump Bannon rinds
Ryan for all these people to be advising
Trump to walk across the aisle Democrat
is just pure I'll idiocy it is so stupid
just mathematically it's idiotic right
now Republicans have 246 votes in
Congress you need to 18 in order to have
majority there are 30 members of the
freedom caucus Trump in that tweet alone
says that he's going to fight Democrat
and the freedom caucus Democrats and the
freedom caucus combined have more than
218 votes okay Democrats admit that
means that Republicans who are not the
freedom caucus and this doesn't even
include the establishment Republicans
who voted against Trump care it has
another 10 to 15
okay that right now Trump is that like
to 16 at the upper limit he's at 216
unless you can feel the way some of
these freedom caucus members by
screaming at them on Twitter and they
apparently don't care I mean if you if
you take a look at how the DS
conservatives are responding Thomas
Massie and representative from
Massachusetts not technically a member
of the freedom caucus but is a very
conservative member of Congress you said
it's a swamp not a hot tub we both came
here to drain it swamp care pools at
seventeen percent sad Justin Amash from
from Michigan he says it didn't take
long for the swamp to drain Trump no
shame mr. president almost everyone
succumbs to the DC establishment and
that's basically right that's basically
right so here's the question where do
Trump's actual sympathies really lie
apparently in a we were told that they
lied with the Mike Pence wing of the
party that they lied that they'd lay
with the louie gohmert wing of the party
that went from content often be an
anti-establishment conservative that is
my friend Dennis Prager sent to be a
conservative dream here's how this
administration is actually broken down
aside from drug courses which he
basically delegated to mike pence in the
heritage foundation to pick aside from
those people everything that he
delegates to his own staffers like the
epa scott pruett the EPA or attorney
general sessions at the DOJ all that
stuff is good everything that Trump
sticks his hands into turns into a mess
because Trump is not actually
conservative and he has very anti
conservative tendencies and that is
obvious at least he has Paul Ryan to
fall back on though Paul Ryan came out
today and he said that me and he said
that it's going to be the Conservatives
who forced Trump to work with the
Democrats which is Ryan's way of kissing
Trump say I hate this sort of the sort
of nonsense this is a joke okay this is
basically saying that if daddy Trump
decides to cheat unmounted conservatives
with mistress Democrats that's just
because mommy conservatives weren't
putting out enough if mommy
conservatives had only been willing to
go along with all the weird things that
daddy Trump wanted to do then it
wouldn't have had to go to Mistress
Democrats for a little bit of pleasing
outside the bonds of the holy matrimony
this is just stupid it's just stupid and
guess who's happy about all this of
course to Mitch McConnell so here's
Mitch McConnell ripping the freedom
caucus I would hate to be a Republican
his vote prevented us from keeping a
commitment we've made to the American
people for almost ten years now
and at some point we'll get down to the
final vote we want you know the one that
that really counts and so I'm optimistic
that none of my members any and want to
be responsible for the status quo on
Obamacare I think the American people
would be deeply disappointed that we
were prevented from keeping our
commitment by Republicans who've in the
end in effect voted for the status quo
pronotum insert image McConnell is a
joke and so is paul ryan when they do
this routine the only people who voted
for the status quo were the people
pushing Trump care which was Obamacare
like the only good thing in Trump care
as I have said now one thousand and
seven hundred and thirteen times the
last count the only good thing in this
bill was Ryan's proposal to change
Medicaid from a block from a from a
need-based grant program to a block
grant program even that was subject to
future change by Congress right now we
are being told that representative chris
collins says the tuesday group which is
another group of Republicans in Congress
met last night and agreed they will not
meet or work with the freedom caucus if
they call just hang up so in other words
the freedom caucus wants to talk about
negotiations and other Republicans are
now ostracizing them because they think
they're going to work with Democrats
well done guys just well done this is
just genius I am so glad that you are
all able to put together such a
wonderful wonderful administration
working with the geniuses like Paul Ryan
Mitch McConnell remember when Donald
Trump was anti-establishment when
exactly does he become the establishment
when he's ripping on the freedom caucus
telling conservatives to go shove it and
telling and talking about his gonna work
with Democrats which Trump's named Jeb
Bush and y'all would be up in arms you
would even your Trump supporters which
is named to Jeb Bush pose exactly the
same thing that he's doing right now at
the freedom caucus and you'd all be up
in arms and you would have a right to be
up in arms because this is a joke it is
a joke Jim Jordan who's on the freedom
caucus representative Jordan from India
he says that the the American Health
Care Act is not the Ten Commandments and
this is coming after ted Poe a member of
the freedom caucus walk saying that the
the freedom caucus would vote against
the Ten Commandments are now trying to
do exactly the same thing Democrats did
with conservatives they're trying to say
that conservatives are intransigent
purists jim jordan says is not the word
transition paris it's the ahta Trumpkin
was crap well Alison there's a little
bit of difference between the Ten
Commandments and a
recent legislation that only 17 for the
seventeen percent of country approves up
so I would just say look at the four
corners of the document look at the
legislation itself what did it do what
didn't it do it didn't repeal Obamacare
fully it didn't lower premiums it wasn't
supported by the Republican Party every
major conservative organization in the
country opposed it and so only seventeen
percent of the country like it so there
is a frankly a big difference between
the Ten Commandments and a piece of
legislation that only seventeen percent
of the country approves up let's fix
that legislation let's do what the
president said let's get let's get a
deal put together but one that
accomplishes what we were sent here to
accomplish that's always been our focus
that continues to be our focus and we're
going to be hard at work making sure we
accomplish that so how's all this
working across the aisle working out for
Trump as I said at the top of the show
Republicans are now caving on his Trump
wall they're not even funding his front
wall in order to get through a budget
resolution you think the freedom caucus
would have gone along with that of
course they wouldn't have the freedom
caucus would have n people calling for
the wall funding but those people are
being exercised by president Trump in
favor of Democrats Mitch McConnell and
Paul Ryan just disgusting well before we
continue on here and I want to talk
about the media and how they are
continuing to to go crazy over just
absolute silly stupid nonsense I first
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Birch gold so if you are
somebody who wants to invest in precious
metals right now you're looking at the
economy thinking yourself i'm not sure
where which way this thing is going to
go if you're worried about threats from
abroad if you're worried about the
instability and financial markets in
europe then now would be a good time to
put some your money in gold and the way
to do that is to call my friends up at
Birch gold calm so i spending go to
Birch gold calm / ben you can get a
comprehensive 16-page freak it that
tells you how gold and silver can
protect your assets and your savings how
you can move your Iowa Tower IRA or 401k
into precious metals you should always
have part of your portfolio in precious
metals I certainly do it ask all your
questions get all your answers and then
when you're ready to invest in precious
metals talk to my friends over at Birch
gold group again they have lots of
five-star ratings they've made plus
rating from the better business bureau
they are the people you'll you're going
to trust with your gold investment Birch
gold calm / then okay so I want to talk
about media's attempts to tear down
Trump not on the basis and the
Republicans not on the basis of their
obvious
and competence which is actually what's
happening but on the basis of just
absolute nonsense but for that you're
gonna have to go over to daily wire.com
I want to talk about this Pence thing
where they're trying to rip down pence
over the awful awful news that he only
likes to eat alone with his wife not
other women as opposed to Bill Clinton
who only likes to eat alone with other
women not as wife we'll talk about that
we will also get to the veil bag and if
you want to be part of the mail bag
today then you need to subscribe go to
daily wire.com right now and check it
out eight dollars a month gets you a
subscription annual subscription gets
you a free signed copy of Michael Mills
best-selling book reasons to vote
Democrat a comprehensive guide sure it's
blank but it's the best gag gift that
you'll ever give anyone is it sold tens
of thousands of copies my quote is on
the front says thorough you can get a
free signed copy of Knowles's book when
you go over to daily wire calm right now
in the annual subscription the Shapiro
store should be coming within the next
month I know I keep saying that but
don't worry my promises are good I'm
like politicians it will happen so we
will make sure that that happens daily
wired com to become a subscriber or if
you just want to listen to the show
later go to iTunes or SoundCloud make
sure you leave a rating over to iTunes
we always appreciate it this is the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
Oh